foreign
[Music]
very few of us know about the walls
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
do you feel responsible
Sarah Olivia first of all
congratulations on this and so I have to
start with you sir because I think it's
so interesting I don't I didn't have
time to count all the movies and all the
appearances and everything but you're
leading this show and really getting us
to take us on a real Nick Fury story
what was that like for you knowing that
again this is your story you're really
like this is your Iron Man in a lot of
ways what my Iron Man if you're a
starring vehicle yeah
um you know I was I was actually happy I
mean people have always been saying well
we need a Nick Fury movie blah blah blah
I always thought you know hour and a
half two hours is not enough to do a
Nick Fury movie so to have six hours uh
to explore this story is great you know
and yes it's a Nick Fury ledge story but
you know all those people that are on
that poster all these people in it have
their own arcs that are pretty complete
and an interesting sort of way and they
all compliment you know nick uh and
their relationships and uh
it's kind of wonderful to do it like I
said you know I mean we're uh we're
we're we're very used to seeing Nick at
work or in the field or doing whatever
he's doing but you know you've never
seen Nick Fury you know take his house
key out and open this door uh go in the
house with him and you know see what's
there you know what's in Nick Furious
refrigerator you know seriously well
what kind of furniture does Nick have
does he have a backyard who cuts his
grass you know there's some other
questions I'm not going to get into
Because the Internet will get all into
spoilers but you know what I'm talking
about Olivia I do have to say I am so
happy that you did this but I am even
more flabbergasted when I learned you
campaigned hard to be in the mcu's is
correct like you were like oh I have to
hear about this because both of you have
such a theater background I could see
you campaigning to be in 12th night and
all that I don't know about this
campaign I mean campaign might be might
be a stronger word but I did find my
agent going well
because I I just enjoyed them so much
and I don't know if she just humored me
when absolutely done yes yes and put the
phone down well to rise but um it this
it came about and I don't know how and
I'm thrilled it did and
um yeah I feel like I feel like a kid in
the Sweet Shop I'm just really excited
well I think folks are going to be most
surprised is you're so lovely you have
me like both of you cheesing right now
but I will say this you're terrifying in
it like you give Dolores average Vibes
in the best way possible how fun was
that because I just don't think many
people would cast you as a villain like
that I know yeah well that's another
thing that's so lovely oh Mom I'm not
saying no I'll go villain us
but go ahead sorry what was that was
that part of the motivation yeah I mean
I would have said yes whatever they give
me but it was really lovely to find out
fun I get to do things I haven't done
before and it's always fun to play
something different if you can and
um and so this was just a win-win for me
one of the things Amelia and Kingsley
and Ben and really everyone is sad
because there is so many theater actors
as a part of this is just how much this
felt like a bit of that like a troop
coming together and I know you and Ben
like starting what you guys were able to
do on Marvel and then coming into this
that must have been really interesting
because you get maybe more reps in
television and more chance to really
sort of develop these characters over
episodic was that really fun doing that
with Ben because y'all really are a
tennis in tennis match scenes and you
have another great one with Don Cheadle
as well where it's like just two great
actors of course yeah but you know Ben
Ben's a fantastic actor Don's a
fantastic actor I mean I've known you
know Don for a very long time watch what
he's done I've watched Ben and all these
other things you know I get animal farm
and all these things what is this dude
you know but I remember when we were
doing Captain Marvel he was always green
he had his mask on most of the time and
he was like you know when we were in New
Orleans working he'd be in a hammock
smoked a cigarette with his green face
on playing his music and Fanning you
know so he was always in that character
so I didn't see him as Ben that much so
it was very different to work with him
this time but the joy and
professionalism of both those actors you
know bleeds into what we come here to do
uh it's very important to trust the
people on the other side and not worry
about you know them holding up their end
they're going to hit their marks they're
going to say their lines and they're not
going to be tedious yeah please don't be
tedious don't be you know don't ask me
about this just let's do it you
know and let's do it and Trust the fact
that we did it and they are both those
people what's yes you don't have to say
how was that you know already you don't
even talk about it you know it's like
that was great
Fury
we gonna be very careful now
there's a lot of father-daughter stuff
going on in here how did you guys
so quickly because I know television you
don't always get as much time as like
theater to sort of build that Bond well
I think we just I mean I'm obsessed with
him before and then I'm now just madly
in love with him having worked again so
that was all it was like it was like a
it was a safe space but also the thing
about acting is it is like tennis you're
better with a better partner and he's
just the best actor I've ever worked
with so it like you're kind of it it
becomes fun it's not in any way
competitive it's just like what are you
gonna do oh and then what am I gonna do
oh and then what are you gonna do oh my
God they're gonna do this like it it
just kind of right yeah yeah no I agree
I agree because it was a big daunting
one and I was actually quite intimidated
but you know because I'm a huge big no I
did anyway but but we just got in and we
were we were nice to each other yeah we
were nice to each other and that allowed
us and then just sort of go places yeah
yeah and I think it ended up like a lot
better like yeah yeah we pumped it
obviously for folks that saw Captain
Marvel your Dynamic is you know
different there's time has passed we're
getting to see you in both those but can
you describe sort of like where we start
secret Invasion what would you say
talios describes the relationship
because it's in a very interesting place
when you guys start off yeah between the
two of you look I I I think well during
they're kind of a bit estranged I mean
I'm aware of uh you know the the shift
in Dynamic I'm not quite we learn a lot
more about what's going on but we are
definitely you know there's a there's a
distance there but I don't think Talos
is aware of just how bad things have
gone yeah it's like a classic
I feel like a classic problematic
father-daughter relationship in that we
are estranged and he maybe hasn't
accepted the change and hasn't been able
to see who Gaia has become in the
interim and who like where where her
journey is actually taking her and the
anger that she has is a very relatable
daughter like frustration yeah that I
think happens and she goes on a journey
of self-discovery
they together go on a journey of
self-discovery of what this relationship
is I think it's so funny too to look at
this because all of the world so much
could have been changed if like you two
and maybe Granite got to therapy
yeah yeah hard time with therapy because
we're so you know we we can take on you
know exactly like we can understand your
feelings and all that exactly
it's very hard to get to ours oh man
they need a whole yeah there's a shell I
do have to ask both of you because like
I'm literally sitting here I'm like
which one do we want to pick Star Wars
Game of Thrones Batman now we're in the
MCU but there clearly is incredible
actors who have a body of work both on
stage and screen that is really
impressive there has to be something
about genre that attracts both of you
because you seem to be going back to it
so I'm just curious Ben starting with
you is it because it's the same no
matter what or is there something
different about these sort of like Grand
sort of sci-fi fantasy Productions you
know what uh it is and particularly
about this they are a great they are
really good people to work with and
people people love this stuff that's
really good too you can what you can
labor for a long time and people not dig
this and that but this here
people love it and and they know what
they're doing and they are the best
people ever to work for what about you
what is it because again after Game of
Thrones I could you could
you get her in romcom for the rest of
your life and I will be happy but there
has to be something that makes you want
to maybe go back and dip in right well
yeah this particular one was different
because if just taking Marvel out of it
for a moment this is grounded this is
espionage this feels different which was
it's always fun to join a franchise when
they decide to do something completely
different be a part of that that was
exciting to me anyway the cast forget
about it like there are all these other
things that are a part of it but I think
when you put something in a Fantastical
space in a kind of magic realism world
as an actor you really get to play you
really really really get to push as many
boundaries as possible and there's kind
of there's no end point which makes it
really exciting and fun and there's some
stuff that we got to do on this where I
was like I am having a good day it's a
good day today I get to do some crazy
what did you do with your day let me
tell you about one of you I'm not going
to because I'm gonna spoil some stuff
but it was fun
for years
you've been avoiding Earth
but I have called for your help plenty
of other times and you've been pretty
content to let those calls go straight
to voicemail
yeah well
first of all congratulations thank you I
think it was really interesting what you
said about this being the most that you
got to sort of live in Mariah and she
really gets the show what was that like
I mean this is I don't know how many
performances deep if you count like the
voices and all the shows yes yes uh what
was that like to sort of like take that
leap and back in something that you're
familiar with episodic television you
know well my job on these projects is
really
um to give the audience the information
like hi this is what just happened this
is what we're trying to do and give
great face to Nick Fury and a little
little sasta fury that's literally my
job so it was really thrilling to me to
be able to have a heart-to-heart scene
with Fury in this and not have to play I
mean certainly there are moments of
we've got to get to A to B
um we got to move the story along
logistically and um but in this you got
to
got more of the sense of what the
relationship is between these two people
who have been working together for a
very long time you're able to sort of
get a get a sense of what the world is
you know and it's not glamorous you know
that's also a big difference is
the first Avengers we were on a
spaceship
like we were in that we were floating in
the sky and
so that when you take we were in Stark
Tower for the segment you know there's
these Grand sets and in this one we're
literally sitting around a table like
cooking popcorn in Moscow so it's it
just had a gravitas that I hadn't been
able to
um experience um in previous
Marvel things the one thing I will say
though for exposition whatever you had
to do they're still iconic moments
because I will never forget he's fast
and she's weird like that is like yeah
and that was Exposition and it was like
iconic it's true yeah that was a good
like we got the jargon but also that's
what we're trying to say that's pretty
good
I will say it's also great that you get
to work with Sam so closely it's like so
many folks honestly in the MCU don't
even get to spend that much time yeah
because it pops in and out but what is
it like for you guys because you're
right the characters in this one really
talk about what they mean to each other
there's I think a lot of people are
going to be talking a lot about your
character let's just go ahead and put
that out there with this for sure so
what was it like sort of knowing that
the fans are really going to get to see
a different look and emotionality around
your character yeah well I think it's
you know it it's funny because we're
talking about like they have all these
conversations but Fury's not giving me
anything yeah like Fury is not he is
playing a very close to the chest and he
is not
um opening up at all and that's
extremely frustrating and and seemingly
not aware of the current situation and
what we're up against and so I think
that's sort of what's creating the
tension and we get to see Maria for the
first time calling him out on stuff that
I mean you know how terrifying that is
like I mean it's terrifying to call Sam
out on stuff you imagine how terrifying
it would be to call out Nick Fury on
something
like be in touch with your emotions like
let's yeah it's it's those are tricky
things to do but it shows just what kind
of relationship they have that she's
able to ask those questions because I
don't know many other people who could
yeah that's that's such a great point
because I will say for wherever folks
are with this series pretty much from
episode one they're gonna be learning
things about these characters that
they've never seen before they're gonna
be very surprising what would you say
will be the most surprising things that
fans are gonna figure out about some of
these longer characters like yourself
infuriating someone like telios um what
do you think is the most surprising
thing that folks are maybe going to
figure out through this spy Thriller
yeah well I think that a lot of promises
were made and I think that there's
always conversations about Stakes on
these projects and with each project you
have to like rewire because you're like
okay I know this is happening but also
do you remember when like there was that
crazy alien attack that we all went
through okay and so you kind of have to
you go where are we now with the
experience that we've had and how does
that work with with the emotion and this
one it was kind of it was kind of easy
because there was already so much
history and
what was boiling to the surface was the
frustration of
um Fury's lack of action and uh
obviously lack of presence but um
so I think that we're able to sort of
play off of the things that we've
experienced in the past and bring them
like there it's much more nuanced as I
think what I'm trying to say is having
these scenes we have such a history that
it just builds the current scenes that
we're in there's a lot of new faces that
are part of this Kinsley um Olivia and
Amelia who do you think folks are going
to be most surprised and what they do
from these newcomers because those three
alone are just like you're right it's
it's such a wonderful cast I think like
Kingsley Ben is like he's dark and hard
to to to to to
break down and you don't you really
don't know what's coming from him I'm I
mean Amelia is so amazing and I think
that her story arc is is incredible and
she's so talented Olivia Coleman I think
is the most maybe the it will kind of
take people by surprise because it's
Olivia Coleman who's so funny and
charming and
um likable
and she's really intense in in this
series and she's really dark
she does some pretty nasty things with a
smile yes yeah which is the worst yeah
it's it's it's it's it's deadly
the Great Neck Fury
first of all Kingsley congratulations
thank you performance I was just
thinking one night in Miami it's nice to
see you have legs to see you in person
yeah first impressed but it's such a
bizarre type moment of just me and
everyone on a screen and now you see
over here yeah but I do have to ask you
because that was sort of our
introduction to you but you were a
decade into your career but joining the
MCU has to feel like something a little
bit different what made you want to join
it how familiar with like with it were
you like I need to get into the MCU or
is this just the role it was just the
role you know it was just the role yeah
the producers approached a couple of
weeks after one night in Miami came out
and so I didn't think that that wasn't a
coincidence they came to me for this
this villain role which I was sort of
sort of wondering you know wanted to
know more about it and then we I just
had some great conversations with the
producers about the story what they were
going for they wanted to go for a darker
tone maybe like a thriller and I was
like yeah this is a completely different
direction for me and and uh
yeah just as we spoke more about the
character there's a couple of scenes
they sent me taste the scenes for some
stuff with salmon and Ben
and I was like
this is gonna it's gonna be cold oh I
love that I mean you come from like the
theater world and I know that it is
about the performance and so much of
that but when you are playing a villain
one thing that's sort of like unique to
the MCU or I would say just good
villains in general is feeling that you
understand the reason why they're doing
what they're doing even if they're going
about it in a hard way is that something
that you think folks are going to take
with granite because he's a very
charismatic villain uh I hope so it was
definitely important to me like
understanding like the wife the why of
his behavior like and and trying to get
underneath
what kind of things must have happened
to him what his experiences must have
been on Earth and before to lead him to
like behave in these like atrocious ways
yeah and just like that someone so
full of hatred who who really trusts no
one at like the the beginning at the
point certainly when we meet him it's
like yo this guy doesn't trust anyone
unless without giving any spoilers away
there was just a few indications from
the right and that like
like the infliction of suffering like
how important it is for him to have Fury
and Talos experience that to experience
him inflicting it on them felt really
kind of sadistic if not sociopathic and
I was like yo I've never been approached
to play anyone like this and like even
if the writing wasn't perfect in all the
places there was a collaborate
collaborative enough environment to like
and try and hold a true psychological
thrill land and adjust and tweak and
just make sure that he felt really
grounded all along the way because you
know Olivia and Sam and Ben the human
was going to come yeah from other places
so for me it was just about holding
holding as dark attention as possible
and to yeah just to make him satisfying
to me was like
really trying to lean away from any
sentimentality that it wasn't it's not
us against them it's I don't think he
feels anything for anyone at this stage
at some point he did so yeah the why
like why he's behaving like this and how
he arrived at this place
like we we that that
we kind of tried to weave that in as
much as possible so that the audience
could go away again I kind of understand
where he's he's coming from you know I
grew up with a lot of guys who have
behaved in similar ways or like you know
there was a lot to draw from and now
let's be honest having Ben Mendelson and
Samuel L Jackson as and Olivia Coleman
as seeing Partners is not a bad way it
was the draw I'm not man liver didn't
have so much which kind of should be
uncertain and she's leaving and I'd go
on and but Sam and Ben yeah that they
were to draw if I'm honest with you it
was those two it was like the producers
approached and then it was it was the
stuff with those guys I was like yeah no
this is a this is a this is a must I
hadn't worked in a while
we ask you this though about it is
because you're putting them literally on
their heels through most of the story at
least the part that we've kind of gotten
to see that's got to be a really
intriguing thing because most of the
time when you're acting with actors
alongside that you know maybe it's like
one night in Miami where you guys are
doing this Ensemble you were literally
getting to be in like a very like
Wimbledon s like I give it to you as
hard as you give it to me with these
what was that like that's coming with
these guys that's like what was it like
doing that like that whole like back and
forth really fun because we watched the
first two episodes last night was like
oh wow there's so much more to come you
know I mean they just this is just this
is just the beginning yeah so like it's
kind of exciting but yeah the back and
forth was awesome like Sam Sam in
particular is the same the scene towards
the end was a real like Showdown and he
yeah that we had some great you can't
get it every time because we're trying
to keep an organic flow and we're trying
to find like we're trying to find real
chemistry moments but every now and
again we get a couple of tapes with it
oh I hope they keep that you know exam
would do something he'd be like oh
that's cold you know Ben as well man
like whenever the
yeah Ben can just don't take four just
randomly do something so beautiful and
that's what kind of made the experience
really special that's what I love about
acting as well is that you go like you
know if we we really commit and
everyone's prepped and we do our
homework you can create these like real
moments of explosions of you know
different emotions and stuff so uh yeah
I think we achieved that in different
business so it's funny that you say that
that because you're right everything
kind of shut down and now a lot of this
work that you were working on through
covet is now coming out between this and
Barbie and soon to be Bob Marley I just
have to say you know for folks that got
introduced to us then talk about this
moment and like having all these three
projects come out like in this quick
succession how are you feeling about
this year I mean like literally one of
the biggest television shows movies and
biopics of the Year probably it's
glorious to work man you feel so really
lucky like I'm just like still working
I've left yeah just feel really grateful
and they've been they've been three
wildly different but like like beautiful
experiences in their own different ways
and like to do Bobby straight after this
was nuts and then to be like prepping
Bob as I was doing Barbie was insane and
then it all just kind of came to an end
a few weeks ago
gone holiday and absorb you know so but
it's you know lucky man lucky can you
give us just a little bit I I feel bad
even asking this can you give us just a
little bit of preview of what folks can
expect with those two projects since
we're talking about this one like give
me a little bit of one-liner on Barbie
and then also with the Bob Marley Bobby
I'm like I think I'm more excited than
anyone to see it because that was like
that was the best script I ever read it
was hilarious like it was funny as hell
and so I'm really excited to see that
and Bob I think
you know it was there was kind of a
beautiful chaos about the whole creation
of it and the family were right there
like Ziggy was
Ziggy was with me every day you know so
and some of Bob's best friends were
behind the camera so it was I mean I
haven't absorbed like what the hell just
went down with that like but what
what a treatment like to play to play
him and to
just just on a musical level
to get to spend that amount of time
studying the music and the dancing and
the singing and the team I had around
like it was
it was nuts this is my War alone
and on the last person standing between
them and what they really want
and what is that
first of all congratulations on the
series I just have to say what was it
like as a director first of all you have
this incredible cast but on top of that
these sort of like incredible locations
where you guys are having to film and
just sort of this sort of expansive
Global spy Thriller how did you balance
those two balance the cast and the
location sort of like this Grand scale
of the series yeah oh yeah I don't think
of it as a balance I think of just
ramping up ramping up ramping up the
best most amazing cast in the world
coupled with stunningly beautiful
locations and it just keeps ramping up
and giving somebody like me an
opportunity to tell a visual story in
the best way possible one thing I think
Marvel's did a great job with the
marketing they're really making the
making the secret Invasion and so
there's a lot of unanswered questions
even sort of going into the series what
do you think audiences can get prepared
for because I think they'll it's a
different type of even what the MCU has
done to this point on series or on
screen I think uh to your point get
prepared for the unexpected
um you know I'm not going to reveal
story points and I think the whole tone
of it it's something that's very
different from the MCU but it's
something that people have to sort of
ride in and not be prepared for
one thing I think
a process the process of directing this
that you didn't maybe expect going into
like pre-production because there's
always new things that sort of come up
along the way
um I think the way Marvel Works uh their
process it's a constant
constant series of Explorations and
discoveries all along the way there are
no hard and fast scripts hard and fast
anything you go in with the actors and
the producers and the people at Marvel
and you just keep exploring along the
way and revealing and in a way that's a
bit of a challenge because production
production is a a moving freight train
and it's also exploring along the way so
it's a big it's a different challenge
but um rewarding in its own way because
you you always feel like you're
peeling back the onion and exploring a
new story
uh one of the great things I would say
with this is definitely the cast but in
addition to that this is a Marvel story
and you have at the sort of you know
first name on the call sheet a man who's
been in probably more iterations of this
whether it be Voice or on screen or on
television what was it like having Sam
as a partner in this both as somebody
that has been so intricately involved in
the MCU but also someone who literally
just loves genre and genre filmmaking
and this type of filmmaking he's a great
collaborator and I think this was a
great piece to collaborate on with him
because it's the Nick Fury story in many
ways at least he's the the entry point
and the heart and the soul of this story
and that has never been explored in the
MCU that version of Nick Fury and I he
was really open to it and ready for it
and it was very exciting for me one of
the things we got to talk to him about
was specifically the idea that we get to
see more of Nick Fury we get to see well
he said and we get to see him at home we
get to see him literally open the door
to his house which is something that
you've never seen before what was
intriguing to you about that as a
director sort of peeling back the layer
of this character that the audience you
know that you're producing it for is
very familiar with and so you kind of
get to really have fun with this
backstory well the nice thing is I don't
think the audience is familiar with this
Nick Fury they're familiar with that
Nick Fury which is very different from
now let's go home with him and let's go
inside and find his fears and
vulnerabilities and questions which is
something the Nick Fury character has
never done before so it was a new
exploration not
um you know hanging on to an old one and
trying to make it fresh I think it's a
completely new exploration into the
character that's really interesting um
one of the things that all the actors
mentioned is there's these incredible
moments um because it is more of like a
play in a lot of ways there's there's
family Dynamics there's like long seated
uh trauma and history that are being
explored it's almost Shakespearean and
some of these scenes between these two
characters there's been great ones that
we've already heard about between like
Don and Sam there's scenes that have
been alluded to between Sam and like uh
Mariah there's there's also scenes of
like what graphic Kingsley does what
Amelia does is there one you're
particularly wanting to keep audiences
on the lookout for where it's like again
what they like to call this tennis match
of two great actors um apparently
there's some between Ben and Sam as well
um is there one you want audiences to
keep out for maybe an episode that you
want audiences to sort of like it's I
wish I could single something out I I
have such affection for every actor
that's in there they're a great long
interesting scenes between Sam and
Olivia between Sam and Ben between Sam
and Don between Sam and Amelia between
Ben and Amelia I think there's electric
performances across the board awesome
all right so they have a bath of riches
to choose from I hope so honestly tell
them uh it's interesting that this is
the timing of the show I mean you guys
literally had a like secret message
marketing campaign where people are
going to like different websites and
like putting in secret codes it's weird
to have that happen at the same time
there's like extremely renewed interest
just an alien invasions that's got to be
kind of an interesting moment for you as
a director when you guys were making
this you did not think that like literal
like UFO sightings and this sort of idea
of a secret Invasion would be part of
the Consciousness does that like kind of
intrigue you even more now as a director
it's like a layer to the story you
didn't intend that now plays against the
audience it's a gift it's a gift if
that's why you take it as that yeah it's
like it's yeah it's a gift it's a gift
to the the marketing it's a gift to the
audience's experience that it feels more
real and grounded to their their
experience of life